hi everyone happy new year and welcome
to our special event
i will kick it off with gaming and
creators and then alikhani will talk
about developments in autonomous
vehicles so let's get started
this
this is beyond the game
[Music]
this is an epic journey
into a vast unknown
through countless ages
and across infinite galaxies
of untold beauty
and
unfathomable danger
where you carve your own path
always outnumbered
never outgunned
chasing down destiny
as you peer into the eyes of your feet
and quietly saying
you're next
yes
this is what you're here for
this is why
this is your world
so what are you waiting for
rtx
it's on
gaming is huge people no longer ask if
it will keep growing of course it will
now the question is how big will it get
there are almost 3 billion gamers in the
world with 150 million more people
gaming this year
today the market for games and gaming
hardware is almost 300 billion dollars
up 70 billion dollars from just three
years ago
esports continues to be an important
driver
league of legends world's 2021 finals
drew 74 million peak concurrent viewers
the 2021 dota 2 international paid out a
40 million dollar prize pool
all told esports has an online audience
of 460 million viewers and people are
tuning in to all types of gaming content
there are now 10 million unique
streaming channels on twitch
doubling over the past two years
750 million people watched gaming
content online in 2021
and the gaming universe is expanding
into virtual worlds with their own
economies
roblox has attracted 200 million monthly
users
little nas x hosted a concert inside
roblox in front of 33 million fans
this is also fueling virtual reality
where headsets are expected to grow four
times in the next four years
but it's not just about playing
there are 45 million professionals and
freelance creators fueling an explosion
in digital content
they will become the builders of our 3d
digital worlds
and as the gaming experience extends
into these vast open virtual worlds some
see an opportunity in the trillions
over the past 20 years we have dedicated
ourselves to build the best platform for
gamers and creators
not just to delight our customers but to
develop graphics technologies that
enable game developers and creative isvs
to do some really amazing work
at the heart of the platform is our gpu
and a history of revolutionary
architectures like rtx
all told we have shipped almost one and
a half billion gpus
and on top of the hardware comes a
massive investment in our software stack
that harnesses the gpu to deliver
graphics innovations like game ready
drivers dlss g-sync reflex nvidia
broadcast max-q
omniverse and g-force now with billions
of devices unable to play the latest
games it's no surprise that cloud gaming
is expected to grow to over a hundred
million subscribers by 2024.
for these gamers we've built geforce now
delivering geforce class gaming to over
15 million members around the globe on
chromebook max shield tv android and ios
phones and underpowered pcs
geforce now has over 1100 pc games
including 90 free to play
from the leading pc game stores
including steam epic games ubisoft
connect and ea origin and extending our
partnership with ea i'm excited to
announce that battlefield 4 and
battlefield 5 are available on gfn
starting today
be sure to tune in to gfn thursdays
where every week we onboard new games
for our members
we've also been working with the world's
largest tv manufacturers to bring
geforce now to millions more living
rooms
last month we launched a beta version of
gfn on lg 2021 web os smart tvs
today we're pleased to announce a
partnership with samsung
to integrate geforce now into their
smart tvs
starting in q2 samsung smart tvs will be
streaming pc class gaming with gfn
the rapid expansion of 5g offers the
potential for low latency cloud gaming
everywhere so we've teamed with at t and
their fast reliable 5g network to bring
the power of pc gaming to mobile devices
as a 5g technical innovation partner
geforce now on the att 5g network offers
ultra-responsive cloud gaming on the go
we also have an exclusive offer to
announce
starting today att customers with a 5g
device on a qualifying plan can get a 6
month geforce now priority membership at
no charge
geforce now members get access to the
latest geforce technology
our new rtx 3080 tira service powered by
the geforce now super pods is the first
to support 120 frames per second at
1440p on pcs up to 1600p on macbooks and
4k with hdr on shield tv
available today at just 99 for a
six-month membership play the most
demanding pc games no waiting no
downloads on the latest geforce rtx
hardware in the cloud
rtx momentum continues to build
ray tracing and ai are defining the next
generation of content since last ces
we've added over 150 rtx games and
applications
and gamers have logged over 1 billion
hours of rtx playtime
the day before from fintastic is an open
world mmo survival set in a deadly
post-pandemic america overrun by flesh
hungry infected and survivors it's in
the top 10 most anticipated games on the
steam wish list today we're announcing
the day before will launch june 21st
with rtx on including ray tracing and
dlss on geforce and geforce now here's a
first look at the day before with rtx on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with over 70 million players tom
clancy's rainbow six siege from ubisoft
has become one of the biggest
competitive shooters the next game in
the series rainbow six extraction gamers
will compete in a tactical co-op fps as
they engage contain and eliminate the
mysterious creatures known as the
archaeans today we're announcing that
rainbow six extraction launching january
20th will be rtx on featuring dlss
and available on geforce and geforce now
here's a first look at dlss in rainbow
six extraction
[Music]
[Music]
escape from tarkov is an online first
person action game players battle
through the war-torn city of tarkov
which has been sealed off by u.n and
russian military forces escape from
tarkov quickly became one of the top 10
most played competitive shooters last
june rtx gamers gained a competitive
edge with nvidia reflex
we are extending our partnership with
battlestate games to bring more
performance with the addition of dlss
let's take a look
[Music]
everybody on me
give us
[Applause]
[Music]
dying light the tremendously successful
open world action rpg by teclan had over
23 million players worldwide the highly
anticipated sequel dying light 2 will be
launching february 4th with rtx on
featuring ray tracing and dlss it's
available on both geforce and geforce
now
here's an exclusive look at never before
seen rtx on action
uh
[Music]
for competitive gamers milliseconds are
the difference between winning and
losing we asked gamers to check out the
benefits of lower latency gaming with
our system latency challenge
early results show up to 2 times aiming
improvement and this is why 8 of the top
10 competitive shooters have integrated
nvidia reflex our low latency gaming
platform
and gamers love it over 20 million
geforce players compete with reflex on
each month and the hardware ecosystem
continues to grow
our reflex latency analyzer allows
players to easily measure system latency
with a single click of the mouse we now
have over 50 reflex mice and monitors
from 16 partners while reflex is
critical for competitive matches lower
latency is important in any game as it
better connects the gamer and their
physical actions to those in the game
today we are announcing seven more
reflex games and extending reflex into
new genres
these include iracing where you can
steer with better precision in the
world's premier online racing simulator
rainbow six extraction where reflex has
your six as you confront archaeans and
sony's award-winning god of war
beat the boss with better dodges and
combos when it launches on pc on january
14th
let's take a look
ready yourself boy
um
with the global growth in esports the
demand for esports displays has been
doubling each year
we believe the time is right to take
esports to a new level today we're
announcing a new category of esports
displays 1440p 27-inch g-sync and up to
360 hertz with new esports vibrance and
reflex latency analyzer these displays
are also dual format they can switch to
1080p 25 inch if that's preferred for
certain games here's seth to fill in the
details
1080p displays have ruled esports for
over a decade as the lower resolution
has enabled higher frame rates and
faster refresh rates but our research
shows that larger higher resolution
panels improve aiming performance
providing larger and more detailed
targets to acquire in fact 1440p 27-inch
displays can improve aiming by up to 3
over traditional 1080p 24-inch displays
for competitive gamers that's huge with
today's high-end geforce rtx gpus
rendering esports games well above 360
fps at 1440p the industry is primed for
a change today nvidia is announcing a
new class of 1440p 27-inch g-sync
esports displays these displays feature
industry-leading refresh rates up to 360
hertz for the smoothest lowest latency
gaming esports tuned vibrance color
profiles powered by mini led backlights
and oxide transistors make targets pop
from the screen an enhanced easier to
use reflex analyzer automatically
measures system latency so gamers can
head into competition with full
confidence in their pc's performance and
if gamers still want to play a match at
1080p the monitor features a special
dual format 25-inch 1080p mode
the future of esports monitors is here
with new displays available soon from
aoc asus msi and fusonic
a decade ago we introduced the 50 class
gpu offering gamers great performance on
the latest architecture at an affordable
price it was the first step up into gtx
gaming in fact three of the top five
gpus on steam are gtx 50 class and one
of the most successful is the gtx 1050.
when it was released in 2016 the gtx
1050 could power the top games of the
time at over 60 frames per second but
the production value of games continues
to rise and modern games need much more
gpu horsepower
the gtx 1050 struggles to keep up even a
1050 ti or the more modern gtx 1650
can't power the latest games at 60
frames per second
today we are announcing the rtx 3050 the
geforce rtx 3050 brings the performance
and efficiency of the ampere
architecture to more gamers than ever
before it powers the latest games at
over 60 frames per second based on our
ampere architecture the 3050 comes
equipped with second generation rt cores
for ray tracing and third generation
tensor cores for dlss and ai for the
first time you can play ray trace games
on a 50 class gpu at over 60 frames per
second
ray tracing is a new standard in gaming
and the 3050 makes it more accessible
than ever the rtx 3050 comes equipped
with 8 gigabytes of g6 memory and
starting at just 249 it will be
available worldwide on january 27th from
all of our partners
with 75 percent of gamers still on gtx
gpus this is the perfect time to step up
to rtx
we're at the dawn of the next digital
frontier interconnected 3d virtual
worlds whether for commerce
entertainment creativity or industry are
being built today
these worlds are boundless and will be
populated with shops homes people robots
factories museums an infinite amount of
3d content and they will be built by an
expanding number of creators
collaborating across the globe
constructing these amazing virtual
environments for this future we've built
nvidia studio a fully accelerated
platform for creators
it starts with rtx the most advanced gpu
architecture with hardware acceleration
for ray tracing simulation and ai
and nvidia high performance video
processors
the nvidia studio software includes
specialized drivers and dozens of sdks
which accelerate over 200 of the
industry's top creative applications we
also offer our own studio apps with the
latest edition nvidia omniverse for 3d
design and collaboration
today we are announcing that nvidia
omniverse is out of beta and generally
available to geforce rtx studio creators
3d content is challenging to produce
it typically requires multiple tools
which are often incompatible and then
you have to wait for long render times
omniverse brings over 20 years of
invidious groundbreaking work in
graphics ai simulation and compute into
a single platform to transform 3d
workflows
let me explain how it works
omniverse connects independent 3d design
worlds together into a shared virtual
space
the connecting language of omniverse is
usd or universal scene description which
you can think of as the html of 3d
worlds
today a 3d artist typically works
sequentially across multiple
applications like 3ds max for modeling
then substance painter for texturing and
finally unreal engine to arrange the
scene
exporting and importing large files many
times along the way
with omniverse artists connect their
apps and then compose the combined scene
using omniverse create
once in omniverse an artist can draw on
nvidia's super powers
like physics which can let artists use
true to reality simulations that obey
the laws of physics
an rtx renderer to see the scene in real
time fully retraced or path traced
omniverse also lets you collaborate with
another artist from across the room or
across the globe connecting their
favorite apps into a single shared scene
changes made by one designer are
reflected back to the other artists like
working in a cloud shared document but
in 3d
this is the future of 3d creation and
how virtual worlds will be built
[Music]
oh
yeah
[Music]
did you know that white rhinos and black
rhinos are both gray
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we are partnering with over 40 isvs to
transform 3d workflows today omniverse
is connected to leading applications
like 3ds max maya blender unreal engine
and many more to come
we now have several new additions to
omniverse today we are announcing an
even easier way for artists to
collaborate with nucleus cloud now in
early access nucleus cloud simplifies
omniverse scene sharing it's one click
to collaborate and your entire 3d scene
is online
leading 3d marketplaces are now
featuring omniverse ready assets check
out the collection of free assets now
available in the omniverse launcher
omniverse machinima has been a big hit
with creators who love to game it lets
you remix and recreate your own game
cinematics with thousands of game assets
and environments
we are now adding mechwarrior 5 and
shadow warrior 3 assets to the machinima
library
audio to face is a revolutionary ai
enabled app that easily animates a 3d
face with just an audio track
we are now supporting blend shape and
direct export to epics metahuman
ai powered by nvidia studio opens up new
capabilities for creators individual
artists can now do the work of large
teams
application developers are quickly
embracing the power of ai for content
creation
adobe lightroom adds ai to quickly
create detailed masks around subjects
topaz labs video enhance ai uses ai to
upscale videos retaining higher details
than traditional upscaling algorithms
adobe 3d substance sampler uses ai to
generate high quality photo real 3d
materials from photographs
and notch uses nvidia maxine pose
estimation to enable creators to drive a
full body rig with a single webcam
nvidia studio also features canvas our
application that instantly converts
brush strokes into photorealistic images
today we are announcing a major update
to the canvas ai
built from nvidia's gogan 2 research the
latest app produces images that are four
times higher resolution with more
detailed elements it also adds new
materials like flowers and bushes
the new canvas app is available free to
download at nvidia.com
gamers and creators have made geforce
high performance laptops the fastest
growing category in pcs in the last year
alone 35 more rtx laptops were sold and
creators have fueled a 3x jump in studio
laptop sales
we are announcing over 160 new laptops
all built around our rtx 30 series gpus
they include a wide range of form
factors like dual screen easels and
convertibles there are new 14-inch
portable powerhouses and even more
g-sync and 1440p displays
as more gamers and creators turn to
laptops for their primary pc performance
expectations continue to increase at the
same time they are demanding sleek form
factors and longer battery life
in 2017 we reimagined gaming laptop
design with an extreme focus on
efficiency
we developed a system design approach
that delivers high performance in thin
gaming and studio laptops
we called it max-q
it has fundamentally changed how laptops
are built
with the help of ai we optimize
everything the gpu cpu fans display
board design laptop construction even
optimal settings for games
today we are announcing the fourth
generation max-q technologies
let me show you what we've done
on laptops power is shared between the
gpu and cpu
cpu efficiency is critical for
maximizing performance
so we developed cpu optimizer
we've worked with cpu vendors to create
a new low-level framework enabling the
gpu to further optimize the performance
temperature and power of next generation
cpus
as a result cpu efficiency is improved
and power is transferred to the gpu for
more gaming performance
for creators and students who rely on
compute heavy apps like adobe premiere
blender or matlab we've developed rapid
core scaling it enables the gpu to sense
the real-time demands of the application
and use only the cores it needs this
frees up power that can be used to run
the active cores at higher frequencies
delivering up to three times more
performance for intensive creative work
on the go on top of the great
performance laptop gamers also want more
battery life
battery boost 2.0 has been totally
re-architected
now ai controls the whole platform
finding the optimal balance of gpu and
cpu power usage battery discharge image
quality and frame rates all in real time
the result is great playability on
battery with up to 70 percent more
battery life
our fourth generation of max q
technologies with cpu optimizer rapid
core scaling and battery boost 2.0
continues our commitment to bring thin
high-performance laptops to gamers and
creators
today we are announcing the rtx 3080 ti
laptop gpu
bringing the flagship 80 thai class of
gpus to laptops for the first time
featuring 16 gigabytes of the fastest
gdr6 ever shipped in a laptop the rtx
3080 ti delivers higher performance than
the desktop titan rtx
rtx 3080 thai laptops start at 24.99
the rtx 70 family is our fastest growing
class of laptop gpus
introducing the rtx 3070 ti
it's 70 percent faster than the rtx 2070
super laptops and delivers a hundred
frames per second at 1440p
rtx 3070 ti laptops start at 14.99
and laptops powered by both of these new
gpus will be available starting february
1st
for creators looking for the best laptop
for your work we are also announcing new
nvidia studio laptops
with the latest rtx gpus these laptops
are seven times faster than the newest
macbook pro 16 in 3d design
with rtx hardware accelerator ray
tracing ai nvidia's high performance
video processor they are the perfect
tool for any creator workflow
together with nvidia omniverse studio
laptops are ready to build the virtual
worlds of the future with over a hundred
studio laptop designs there's a wide
variety to meet every creator's needs
this includes ultra portable 14-inch
thin and light perfect for remote
workers or students like the new razer
blade
dual display laptops for video editors
like the new asus zenbook pro duo and
the most powerful laptops for creators
like the new msi creator z17 featuring
rtx 3080 ti
let's see what digital artist jacob
norris can create in 48 hours with a
powerful 3080 tie laptop
[Music]
so my name is jacob norris i'm a 3d
environment artist working in games and
films gaming does inspire a lot of the
artwork that i create
games i'm playing now games i've played
in the past
i actually get a lot of the inspiration
for what i want to work on while i'm
traveling having a laptop with me with a
nice big screen a nice powerful gpu that
allows me to work in all the 3d programs
i need just helps me to get my ideas out
as they're coming to me
nvidia reached out to me with the
opportunity to test out this new laptop
the razer blade 17. i'm going to create
a couple scenes with it it's got a
nvidia geforce rtx 3080 ti in this thing
so it's going to be pretty powerful all
right let's do it
this is pretty sweet because actually
i've got the entire scene over right now
which is a huge number of polygons it's
able to glide around the scene with no
issues and try to get some of those
rocks kind of blending in and it'll look
a lot better once we get it into
omniverse and we can get that texture
loaded up on top of here
this is that same landscape scene and
i'm able to open it in blender make
those changes to the landscape bring it
right back into omniverse and it's a
seamless transition
and i'm able to just drag and drop in
this dune buggy character that i got
from my friend we can start playing with
some of the sunlight inside the space
and the shadows just change instantly
it's kind of fun
all right so i got the camera animations
in
let's try this out and see how it works
[Music]
yeah yeah that's really cool i like that
jacob describe your overall experience
with this laptop i wish you had given
this thing to me sooner my life would
have been way easier we were able to
easily render all this stuff no problem
inside of omniverse in such a short
amount of time i feel like i can go
anywhere with it and still am able to
produce the quality artwork that i could
do at home
[Music]
i kind of want to run away with this
thing
this is over right i'm getting out of
here see you guys you guys figure it out
to recap gfn delivers the ultimate cloud
platform for pc gamers today we are
bringing more games more devices and
more networks to the gfn ecosystem
rtx is the new standard and the geforce
rtx 3050 makes it more accessible than
ever
with 75 of gamers still gaming on gtx
gpus this is the perfect time to step up
to rtx
laptops are the fastest growing pc
platform
today we announced 160 new laptop
designs including our latest laptop gpus
the 3080 ti and 3070 tie and our fourth
generation max-q technologies
we announced nvidia omniverse for 3d
design collaboration is now generally
available for geforce rtx and studio
creators this is the future of 3d
content creation and how virtual worlds
will be built
over the past 20 years we have dedicated
ourselves to building the ultimate
platform for gamers and creators and
today we continue that journey but
there's one more thing
the rtx 3090 tie
a monster gpu
40 shader teraflops
78 rt teraflops
320 tensor teraflops 24 gigabytes of 21
gigabit per second g6x memory the
fastest ever
the rtx 3090 ti
our next bfgpu tune in later this month
for more details now let me hand it over
to alikani
thanks jeff
i'm here to talk about autonomous
vehicles it's perhaps the most intense
ai challenge but it's also one with the
greatest benefits to society it will
save lives make roads less congested and
change the way billions of people move
around the world
[Music]
there are three core pillars of the
machine learning pipeline being
developed at nvidia to create automated
driving solutions that can be used by
the transportation industry first is the
real-time ai-based software stack
running on an efficient high-performance
supercomputer that goes inside every
vehicle second there are ai models
trained on our dgx servers in the cloud
and finally a simulation platform is
required and we've built it on omniverse
it's used both for synthetic data
generation as well as to test and
validate the av system this machine
learning pipeline is never ending
autonomous driving software will need to
continuously develop and improve new
data will be collected and synthetically
generated models will be retrained in
the data center then validated in
simulation before new software is
ultimately updated for use on the road
we've created this end-to-end automotive
platform and modules so that our
partners can use exactly what they need
to speed time to market and build a
product that can stay true to their
brand we have some partners that just
buy our chips and core operating system
while developing their own software
applications other partners like
mercedes-benz rely on us across this
entire stack from our self-driving
software running on nvidia drive
computers in each car to training ai
models in the cloud synthetic data
generation vehicle validation and
testing of new features through
simulation which finally get pushed over
the air into each mercedes-benz vehicle
developing an autonomous vehicle
requires an entirely new platform
architecture and software development
process both the hardware and software
must be comprehensively tested and
validated to ensure they can handle the
harsh conditions of daily driving with
the stringent safety and security needs
of an automated vehicle this is why
nvidia has built and made open the drive
hyperion platform which specifies a high
performance computer and sensor
architecture that meets the safety
requirements of a fully autonomous
vehicle today we are in our eighth
generation of hyperion it has been
adopted by hundreds of automakers truck
makers tier ones and robo-taxi companies
hyperion 8 is designed with redundant
drive orange computers 12
state-of-the-art surround cameras 9
radar 12 ultrasonics one front-facing
lidar and three interior sensing cameras
it's architected to be functionally safe
so that if one computer fails there's a
backup available to ensure that the
autonomous vehicle can drive its
passenger to a safe place we have spent
many years developing a data collection
system with high quality calibration and
time synchronization in 4d so our
partners can leverage nvidia's av
investment and focus their resources on
their own ai application development we
have also defined hyperion with our
standard agx form factor so that
customers can design their autonomous
vehicle to scale across generations of
their vehicles with this standard form
factor an automotive oem can go to
production with a drive or in computer
today and easily plug in a hardware and
software compatible drive outland
computer in the future
today i'm pleased to announce that
leading automotive tier 1 suppliers to
say
flex
quanta vallejo and zf as drive hyperion
8 platform scaling partners together
these partners provide the automotive
ecosystem with world-class tier one
options who can manufacture
production-ready hyperion platforms with
the highest levels of functional safety
and security we're very proud of these
partnerships as they demonstrate how
hyperion aid has quickly become the
automotive industry's most open and
adopted platform architecture and you
will see it start hitting production as
early as this year the transportation
industry is going through a rapid
transformation this change started with
a move from internal combustion engines
to electric motors electric vehicles are
not just better for the environment they
fundamentally improve the driving
experience for consumers they drive more
quietly accelerate faster and they will
last longer over the course of the next
several decades we will see the majority
of cars sold be electric this
transformation has given way to dozens
of new energy vehicle startups they have
reimagined the car starting with a new
vehicle architecture based on
programmable software-defined computers
i'm very pleased to announce that our
drive hyperion platform has been adopted
by leading new energy vehicle oems in
the industry volvo established pole star
is bringing a storied heritage of safe
driving into the modern era with
electric vehicles that emphasize the joy
of driving the upcoming polestar 3 suv
features a centralized compute
architecture powered by nvidia drive
china now the world's largest auto
market has also been very successful
driving the transition to navs with
nearly 20 of all cars sold in china this
past quarter being electric we're really
excited to work with the vast majority
of the leading nev companies in china
including neo xbang liotto r auto and
saic's premium electric vehicle brand im
these new electric cars will get better
and better over time with each over the
air update such companies can benefit
from new business models that are
software driven rather than selling a
car and seeing it degrade once it's
driven out of the dealership the tech
based automotive company manages a fleet
of vehicles that will improve with new
services and functions offered over the
life of a vehicle the potential of these
relatively young electric automotive
companies and their innovative business
models is really disruptive it has
resulted in the market valuing them
higher than car companies that are well
established and produce millions of
vehicles each year ai is not just
transforming passenger vehicles but also
opening up a major opportunity for
disruption in the commercial sector over
the last decade and accelerated by the
pandemic consumer shopping has
dramatically shifted online resulting in
increased demand for trucking and last
mile delivery this trend is expected to
continue with projections starting at
170 billion packages being shipped in
2022 and increasing to 280 billion
packages in 2027.
simultaneously the trucking industry has
been experiencing a significant shortage
of drivers over the next few years this
gap is expected to widen even further
increasing to a shortage of more than
140 000 drivers in the us alone by 2027
and more than a million worldwide we are
now seeing a large number of autonomous
driving services being built to enable
these opportunities that are together
essential to our transportation future
today i'm pleased to announce that too
simple will be building its autonomous
trucking platform on nvidia drive oren
too simple is an exciting company that's
meeting the challenges of today's
trucking and logistics industry with its
scalable autonomous freight network
too simple is already working with the
leading names in delivery including ups
navistar and penske and its technology
has already improved arrival times for
long-haul routes of the u.s postal
service now i mentioned earlier that
developing av is a grand ai challenge
at the heart of ai model development we
need the ability to collect a lot of
data and accurately label it to allow
our ai engineers to build accurate and
safe ai models labeling real world data
can be time consuming costly and
difficult
in fact often the data we are most
interested in using is also data that's
the most challenging to label here are
some examples from our own data set that
are difficult to label including scenes
that are dark blurry or hazy others
contain scenes that are challenging to
understand like occluded vehicles or
pedestrians we also have many scenes
that are not often encountered like
construction zones these issues are the
reasons why av developers need a mix of
real data and synthetic data when
developing their am models because of
all these labeling challenges nvidia has
built drive sim replicator a synthetic
data generator for autonomous vehicle
development
replicator helps our ai engineers to
build up hard-to-label ground truth data
by synthetically generating them from
virtual cameras lidar and radar sensors
within our omniverse simulation platform
in this way engineers can train ai
models even before any real data has
been collected and replicator can label
ground truth in ways that humans cannot
tracking moving objects across sensors
velocity
distance occlusion and severe weather
conditions it's a really powerful tool
for the av developer it's accurate low
cost and it fills in gaps for data not
easily found in the real world
the industry is just getting started on
its path to truly self-driving
technology
most vehicles today are only able to
deliver level 2 driving commonly
referred to as advanced driver
assistance systems that require drivers
to still be fully attentive we are now
starting to see cars classified as level
three that allow drivers to take their
eyes off the road but still remain in
the driver's seat some companies are
also developing level four and level
five solutions that will be truly
self-driving allowing the driver to
become a passenger and even sleep in the
back seat these include autonomous last
mile deliveries hub to hub trucking and
passenger robo taxi the complexity of av
software development is ever increasing
for these different use cases vehicles
targeted for higher levels of autonomy
consume much more data as they're
designed with more sensors each with
higher resolutions for better accuracy
ai networks and software architecture
also increasing complexity as you
require true self-driving all of these
factors result in a large increase in
data center infrastructure required for
self-driving software development
companies investing in basic l2 systems
can have data centers that need just one
or two thousand gpus and then we see
some companies needing upwards of 25 000
gpus when developing full self-driving
systems now our strategy at nvidia is
unique to the industry we help our
partners with computers and software in
the car we also help them with their
infrastructure in the cloud and when our
partners align to our drive hyperion
architecture we can help them connect
their platform in the car
with their infrastructure in the cloud
seamlessly we believe the speed of an
oem's end-to-end autonomous driving
software development flow is the most
critical asset and differentiator
software-defined vehicles will
incorporate two key computers built with
nvidia drive oren so far today i've
talked about the computer for autonomous
driving the drive chauffeur and how it
is an ai assisted driving platform that
can handle both highway and urban
traffic
with the utmost safety using the high
performance compute architecture and
sensor set of drive hyperion 8 drive
chauffeur can drive you from address to
address
but there's another equally important
computer that is needed for a next
generation software defined vehicle and
we call it drive concierge with drive
concierge vehicle occupants have access
to intelligent services that are always
on using nvidia omniverse avatar for
real-time conversational ai
welcome cheryl your calendar shows your
ces hotel check in for tonight if we
leave now we can avoid traffic on 880.
perfect drive me there
activating autopilot
i'm ready to enjoy the ride but it's a
little warm in here
should i roll down the windows or turn
on the air conditioner
you know what open the sunroof
opening the sunroof for now
omniverse avatar connects speech ai
computer vision natural language
understanding recommendation engines and
simulation the technology of omniverse
avatar enables drive concierge to serve
as everyone's digital assistant helping
them with recommendations to make
reservations safely use mobile devices
and provide alerts like if a purse is
left behind in the vehicle it's
personalized to each driver and
passenger giving every vehicle occupant
their own personal concierge are there
any important messages for me there is
one from jensen he asks can you meet for
dinner tomorrow
great can you find me a michelin star
restaurant in las vegas
the first result is nobu located at 3799
las vegas boulevard
who is the head chef there
nobu's head chef is no beaumatusa
what is his signature dish
his signature dish is black cod with
miso
what wine goes well with that
no boo's head some layer recommends a
crisp white wine like a sauvignon blanc
with black cod miso sounds like a winner
are there reservations available for
dinner tomorrow
there is availability for a party of two
at 7 30 p.m
perfect please book it can you respond
to jensen to let him know to meet us
there tomorrow
okay should i send it
yes please
okay sending drive concierge also needs
to be tightly integrated with drive
chauffeur to provide high quality 360
degree 4d visualization inside the
vehicle so the driver can comfortably
sit back and trust the chauffeur to
safely drive
drive chauffeur and concierge together
can do really beautiful things as an
example they can serve as a valet to let
you out at the entrance of your
destination and enable the car to search
for a parking spot on its own and then
when you're ready to leave you simply
summon your concierge who will ask your
chauffeur to drive your car back to you
from ai and the car to ai and the cloud
nvidia is paving the way to safer and
more efficient transportation now we're
still in the early stages of this
exciting journey and i can't wait to see
what our partners develop and deliver to
consumers on our hyperion a platform
starting later this year and beyond
thank you
[Music]
you